I think conservatism to see in
conservatism is all it is is common
sense yeah if you just sit and listen to
both sides and just be objective and
listen to what both sides are offering I
literally do not understand how anybody
could be a Democrat these days Jesus I
mean you got you got women competing
against men you got they pushing all
this stuff on kids with the drag queens
and hysterectomies for girls yeah before
they go into people because they want to
be a man I mean this [ __ ] is this is a
freeing stuff it should not be being
pushed mainstream like it is I think the
breaking point for us is um I vote for
Obama's first term because I I thought
you know I didn't really know I just
voted from because he was black at least
be honest about it yeah I'm being honest
about it but um he was the eye opening
after Obama and I started listening to
both sides I hated Obama so much I
actually voted for Mitt Romney yeah
think of that yeah Obama to flip to
mid-run yeah he was the only option